congressman Bernie Sanders independent
from Vermont senator Mitchell and
Speaker of the House Tom Foley announced
a deal on a budget agreement what's in
the package well I suspect they're gonna
be a whole lot of pages so I can't give
you all the details but let me give you
an overview of what it is going to be in
the package as I understand it number
one for the first time in many years
there's going to be a serious effort to
reduce the deficit we're talking about
close to five hundred billion dollars in
the next five years that's not an
insignificant sum of money second of all
we're going to reverse a policy which
has been going on for a number of years
by which the rich have gotten a lot
richer by receiving significant tax
breaks what this program does is finally
say that the wealthiest people in this
country guess what as a result of the
youth huge tax breaks you got that's one
of the reasons why the deficit is so
high so we're going to ask you to start
paying your fair share of taxes and I
think that's long overdue and secondly
as part of that tax reform process but
this program says to the poor people
working people the low-income working
people in this country that's the people
of making four fifty an hour five bucks
an hour six dollars an hour what we're
going to say to those people is you know
what it's time for you to have a tax
break rather than a very rich so we're
looking at about 21 billion dollars in
earned income tax credits and that means
that there's going to be about a fifty
percent expansion of that program and
that's going to be a real shot in the
arm for many working people especially
those people with children thirdly what
we're looking at is a series of programs
called the Children's initiative Steve
one of the disgraces in this country
today is that the United States of
America has by far the highest rate of
childhood poverty in the industrialized
world talking about twenty-two percent
of the kids in America living in poverty
we're talking about five million
children who are hungry on any given day
we're talking about millions of kids who
haven't received the basic immunization
shots what this program does is make a
major initiative to deal with childhood
poverty I think that's long overdue and
I think it's a step in the right
direction so what you're talking about
is a major immunization program you're
talking about a significant expansion of
the food stamp a program and you're
talking about the Family Protection Act
which begins to deal with a horror of
child abuse in America some pretty good
things in the bill good day from
Washington a couple of hours ago Senate
and House leaders announced a a budget
agreement Republicans let it led by
Senator Bob Dole said that they would
not support the plan details more
details will be coming out in the next
few days the president is expected to
address the country Tuesday evening to
talk about what it all means our guest
for the next half hour is congressman
Sanders of Vermont you met with the
president earlier today as part of his
own lobbying effort to what did he tell
you well we had arranged the meeting
wasn't part of his lobbying effort it
was our effort to say to him that we
don't want to see more compromises in
the Children's initiative and we don't
want to see more compromises in the need
to protect working people and poor
people the Progressive Caucus is a newly
formed caucus which attempts to
represent those people who really have
been getting the short end of the stick
for many many years so we would decide
to do is bring together a number of
members of Congress was trying to stand
up represent ordinary people working
people poor people the elderly against
very powerful forces in this country who
have dominated the political scene for
many many years so we said to President
Clinton and Vice President Gore stand
with the Children's initiative if you
want our support don't cut it back more
stand with the Earned Income Tax Credit
which helps the working poor if you want
our support you've got to protect that
we express some disappointment for
example that there was not more of an
increase in the corporate income tax
there was not more in fact increase in
taxes for the very wealthy we could have
done away with the gas tax that's my
view I don't think we need to do that
and needed to do that but essentially we
asked him to stand with the children and
the workers of America so they can get a
fair shake how much would the average
family earned that would see a higher
tax rate um what is going on now is that
and I think this is absolutely fair the
wealthiest two percent of the population
families in America those earning two
hundred thousand dollars a year or more
would pick up eighty percent of the tax
increases but the president initially
said 115,000 for a for an individual
140,000 for families what we will
out now I'm sorry but is that still the
cut off no I think what we're looking at
now is couples making 180 thousand
dollars a year and single individuals
making 140 thousand dollars a year and
there's also debate whether or not that
would be retroactive to march or january
i think that the what they have
concluded is that it would be
retroactive to january how will this fly
in vermont i think in the polls that
I've seen in my own state and throughout
the country people understand that the
wealthy have ripped off the system
during the last dozen years I mean
everybody knows that during the 1980s
the richest one percent of our
populations or an almost doubling of
their income at the same time as their
tax rates were reduced meanwhile working
people by the tens of millions saw a
decline in their standard of living but
if you look at federal state local taxes
their tax burden went up I think the
truth is the working people and poor
people want to see the rich start paying
their fair share of taxes and will
applaud a program which lowers taxes on
the working poor I think it's going to
play well in Vermont and I think it's
going to play well all over this country
congressman Sanders is originally from
brooklyn new york he is known as second
term and independent the only
independent in the US House of
Representatives we think you know people
who support me or product I suppose our
opponents are not probably is that
formerly a college professor and we want
to get to your phone calls in just a few
minutes you'll see the number on the
bottom of your screen but first Senator
Bob Dole earlier today on the Senate
floor talking about the budget plan and
how Republicans will deal with the issue
everybody wants to reduce the deficit
this is why we support a balanced budget
amendment the Constitution this why
Republicans favor the line-item veto we
remain fundamentally opposed the
president's plan because we believe that
the best way to reduce the deficit and
move toward a balanced budget is to cut
spending first there are a lot of
Americans who may be willing to make a
sacrifice reduce the deficit but they're
not willing to accept higher taxes for
business as usual and that's what this
plan offers congressman will any
Republicans either in the house or the
Senate support the president's plan my
understanding is that none will why well
they're gonna give you a whole lot of
rhetoric but essentially the bottom line
is they want to protect the interest
will be very wealthy this is a very
progressive tax program the richest two
percent
the population are asked to contribute
eighty percent of the new taxes mr.
Dolan as friends are very upset about
that because that's essentially the
group of people that they represent
furthermore working people low-income
workers are going to get a tax break
these guys for years supported tax
breaks for the rich so that you now have
a situation in America where the
wealthiest one percent of the population
owns more wealth in the bottom ninety
percent during the 1980s almost all of
the fifty percent over half of the
increased income in this country went to
the richest one or two percent of the
population that's what reaganomics was
all about and it was a disaster the
result of it was that the vast majority
of our people became poorer ordinary
workers you have two million people
sleeping out on the street and you have
five million children who are hungry you
have 37 million Americans without any
health insurance that's the policies
that those guys gave us now I should
tell you that as an independent you're
not could hear me telling you you know
lining up and saying bill clinton is
great milk lenders do all these
wonderful things I've strong
disagreements with mr. Clinton on a
number of areas but essentially what
this is about is somebody is going to
have to pay more in taxes should it be
middle income and working people or
should it be the very rich this program
asks the very rich to pick up the lion's
share of the burden and that is
absolutely appropriate one other
biographical note congressman Sanders is
the former mayor of Burlington Vermont
that's how you began your political
career I was mayor for four terms and
very proud of what we accomplished them
we're gonna get our first phone call we
also want to show you what's going on as
capitol hill from the steps out front
and out in front of the Capitol you'll
see some of the activity including these
reporters this is a bob franken of CNN
who is feeding his report out to CNN and
a lots of other activity going on as the
budget negotiations wrap up and the
process now is looking at what the
details are we'll get to your phone
calls gainesville florida your next go
ahead please I don't believe we're taxed
too much congressman I believe would
text to little R attacks too much and
its spending this the problem and Steven
I appreciate if you wouldn't cut me off
how much will our deficit be our debt be
increased at the end of the five years
if mr. Clinton's plan goes through
completely which is not his plan which
has been cut and dissected 55 times by
both Congress one minute on how much
will I debt be increase
I believe I'm not sure if your point is
that the national debt will continue to
rise you're absolutely right but at the
end of five years the deficit will be
significantly lower than it is today
does that answer your question caller
sure not at all please please Steven
don't cut me off it's so difficult to
get through that's why I'm keeping you
on the line go ahead and follow up okay
our debt will be increased by between a
trillion and a trillion of the
half-dollar and it's because of the
waste in government spending there's mr.
you should be served please mr. Reagan
started a commission headed by Peter
grace the citizens against government
waste mr. Bowser Charles Bowser the
chief accountant for the government said
that there's 300 billion dollars in
wasteful spending in the government
every year the citizens against
government waste talk about 200 billion
Charles Martin gross wrote a book called
government record way from A to Z he
talks about about maybe 500 billion that
could be saved as you went to a
zero-based budgeting there is nothing in
this plan that is going to reduce
spending as a matter of fact mr.
Mitchell today said there will be no
spending cuts until three or four years
down the road we will increase taxes
retro actively but no spending cuts till
three or four years on the road and then
that smoke and mirrors now that's our
that's the problem with the country and
the Senate according to sam donaldson
the other day passed a bill or proposed
a bill to reduce tea tasting which is
going to save the government a hundred
and some odd thousand dollars in here
free well you see the point is is
they're wasting government of course
there's waste in government but let's be
clear what the Republicans have in mind
it's not tea tasting for a hundred
thousand dollars or the Lawrence Welk
home or other stupid programs like that
there is enormous weight no one is
arguing about it but if you look at the
Republicans deficit-reduction package
which includes no new taxes and only
cuts you're talking about slashing
devastating cuts in Medicare for the
elderly Medicaid for the poor veterans
programs AIDS and to education
homeless aid to the homeless and so
forth and so on there are real cuts
which are going to make life much much
difficult more difficult for the most
vulnerable members of our society so I
think that's a program that I can't
support should we eliminate the massive
amounts of waste in government yes we
should I personally voted against the
supersonic kaleido I don't think we can
afford that now I voted against the
space station I don't think we can
afford that now I am tomorrow going to
bring on the floor of the house a
10-percent an amendment to reduce the
intelligence budget by ten percent I
don't think we should level fund the
intelligence bureaus all right so
there's a lot of ways that we can go
about cutting back programs which do not
hurt the most vulnerable people in our
society but what the Republicans have
come forward come forward with a massive
cutbacks on Medicare in my own state of
Vermont now and throughout the country
you have elderly people today who cannot
afford their basic healthcare needs they
can't afford their prescription drugs
slashes in Medicare Medicaid is in
serious trouble cutbacks and Medicaid
veterans and put their lives on the line
massive cutbacks and veterans programs I
don't think we should be doing that in
this country the lobbying was rather
intense over the past couple of days and
now the details are being worked out on
Capitol Hill Vice President Al Gore is
is on Capitol Hill which are looking at
now is a live picture of his limousine
part of the motorcade in place on the
Senate side others who are leading the
White House effort include budget
director Leon Panetta and secretary of
the Treasury lloyd bentsen former
senator from Texas as we get another
call from bricktown New Jersey good
evening hi and love you Mr Sanders uh I
want you to know where I'm coming from
my husband I've been married 21 years we
never made more than 43,000 between the
two of us ah you keep bringing up the
fact that the wrist you know the risks
are bad people now you people in the
Congress allowed them to have those
breaks that you're talking millions it
wasn't just President Reagan and the
other thing is I came from Hungary in
1956 during the revolution my father
boards over here to have speed and not
only freedom to say what you want go for
economic
freedom and now I find that my
children's were college a snail they
have to work five months out of the year
to pay their taxes now I don't call that
economic freedom and you can't blame it
on a risk you could blame it on the
people they'll let them have the editors
which was Congress okay you very much
okay I don't think you heard me call
anybody bad certainly rich people and
Ernie quote unquote bad then poor people
or anybody else people you judge people
on their character on the way they live
their lives are not in the amount of
money that we have I think the issue is
an issue of justice and whether we think
it's appropriate in this country that
the nation moves to what almost amounts
to an oligarchy and that is you have
some people with incredible wealth while
the vast majority of the people continue
to see a decline in their standard of
living when you talked about you have
college age young people with so do I in
my family and you should know that there
are millions of young people in America
can't afford to go to college can't
afford to go to college because the
incomes of their family are such that
that unable to pay the ever rising cost
of college tuition so I think what we're
fighting for is a little bit of justice
no one is saying rich people are bed
some of us are saying that it is wrong
that the very rich continue to get much
much richer while middle income and
working people continue to see a decline
in that standard of living and what
we're talking about is justice now you
mentioned that it was not just Ronald
Reagan who instituted the tax breaks for
the rich in your absolutely correct i
was not in congress at that time i
certainly would have voted against that
but the point right now is we've got to
undo some of the damage of the 1980s and
give working people and the working poor
a break which they have long deserved
they really need that break we've gotta
fight for that headline from one of the
newspapers this is the los angeles times
with the picture of Senator David born
who announced yesterday on CBS's Face
the Nation that he would not go long
with the President's budget plan he did
vote originally in the Senate our next
call on the original budget plan he will
not vote on the plan when it comes up
later in the week our next call is from
Los Angeles go ahead please good
afternoon President Clinton has the
not kept any promised from his when he
was a candidate what did he promise you
too along with him and vote for tea
scheme of his the President Clinton
didn't promise me anything you know let
me just say a word on promises kept and
so forth and again as an independent I'm
not a Democrat so I don't want to spend
my whole time defending President
Clinton for 12 years you had presidents
who are very very good with photo
opportunities they were very good with
rhetoric and yet the most important
issues facing this country the deficit
health care the decline of our economy
were not dealt with they were not even
seriously debated now while I happen to
disagree very strongly with President
Clinton on health care I believe in a
single-payer canadian-style system
President Clinton supports the NAFTA
agreement I'm very much opposed to the
NAFTA agreement President Clinton
deserves credit for having the guts to
at least address and debate and force
discussion on the most important issues
facing this country 20 years ago this
nation led the world in terms of the
wages and benefits we provided our
workers we were number one today we are
in twelfth place in the world and in
rapid decline now we can do photo
opportunities we can do all kinds of
nonsensical rhetoric but that's the
ultimate reality how do you rebuild
America how do you really deal with the
deficit to Clinton's credit at least he
is trying to address those issues so New
Haven Connecticut good evening then even
mr. Saunders mr. Saunders first of all
I'm 56 years old and all my life I've
been here in the same squabble about the
the economy and the budget and the
deficit and no matter whether there's a
Democrat end or republican in it still
goes up and up and up and they still say
the same thing they're going to cut the
budget and they whether Democrats are in
they say they're going to hit the rich
when the Republicans are in this isn't
that going to tax and you
as an independent should realize this
better than anyone now I've been
watching the congressional voting and
I've noticed that the independent voter
in the house is always voted with the
Democrat now I want to ask of a basic
question are you independent or Democrat
well you see that I'm very proud of
being the only independent but I have
two choices and that is the Democratic
position or the Republican position as
it happens I don't always vote with the
Democrats on occasion I vote with the
Republicans but often given the
alternatives while the Democratic
alternative is not the kind of
alternative that I would like to see I
tend to vote with the Democrats more
than with the Republicans Orlando
Florida you're next good evening caller
lost a call let me read you a quote from
The Wall Street Journal today's edition
it's it talks about the factionalism
among the Democrats and trying to bring
together a budget deal and it begins a
certain by john harwood he says that
whenever representative Tim penny starts
getting comfortable with President
Clinton's deficit reduction program
congressman Bernie Sanders starts
getting queasy goes on to say that mr.
Sanders is a feisty socialist from
Vermont he worries the package spend too
little to begin with on the needy how do
you and other more liberal members of
the House deal with the more
conservative elements in trying to bring
this package together something that you
can all agree timpani happens to be one
of the better members of the House I
disagree with them on a number of things
but Tim's feeling is is that we've got a
cut program after program after program
and he's played a very important role in
that effort and it is not uncommon for
me to vote with them on the other hand
is I've indicated earlier I think that
right now when you're talking about the
nation on earth which has the greatest
gap between the rich and the pool when
you're talking about five million
children in America being hungry today
when people are sleeping out on the
streets when we're having a collapse in
our school systems from one end of this
country to the other when you're having
a tremendous growth in crime because
people are in despair and you have under
you have police departments that are
don't have the manpower that they need I
think it is silly to say that we're not
going to address those problems so the
difference between Tim penny and me is
that I will vote to make significant
cuts in military spending I'm going to
vote tomorrow and lead the effort the
cut
money for the intelligence budget I
don't think we can afford a space
station I'm going to cut fact on the
supersonic kaleido I led the effort so
that we don't put the 500 billion dollar
savings alone bail out onto the backs of
the worker and all of us and increase
the deficit that's where I would cut but
I must be very frank and tell you that
when so many of our people our elderly
people our children are working people
are hanging on by their fingernails when
you're talking about millions of people
in this country who are hungry I am NOT
going to cut back on those programs that
is not what a civilized nation must do
and when it comes to asking the wealthy
to start contributing to the overall
good of this nation I think that they
should i think frankly it is obscene
that you have chief executive offices in
this country who now make a hundred and
fifty seven times what their workers
make that is the largest gap in the
entire industrialized world a hundred
and fifty seven times more income for
the CEO then for the work that is
nonsense so i think we need to realign
priorities in America I need we think we
need to fight for social justice so the
difference between mr. penny and myself
is that I will cut I will vote for
massive cuts this congressman is not
going to vote for the SNL bailout which
is brought to us by crooks wearing fancy
three-piece suits I'm not voting for
that will Tenpenny vote for this plane I
think you'd better ask Tim penny I don't
I don't want to speak for this depending
how do you think you'll vote will show
you another scene from Capitol Hill is
the discussion continues this evening
for the president's budget plan that has
been in the works for the past few
months next call from New Orleans
Louisiana yes sir uh I want to ask two
questions the first being I wanted to
know what the administration and you
understood the doctrine of the Laffer
curve if you can attack the top 1% of
the wealthiest people are you actually
going to produce any revenues yes yes
well wealthy people would seem to divert
their income into to tax breaks and then
attack municipal bonds and things like
that well there will be that effort
you're absolutely right i remember a
last month talking with an account in
the state of Vermont was already
beginning his efforts to try to shelter
money of the wealthy people and so forth
they try to divert it out of taxes but
nonetheless the reason that this policy
in this program and progressive taxation
is being fought so vigorously is
obviously the rich are against it and
the rich do not want to pay their fair
share of taxes owed a yes they will be
paying more in taxes significantly more
Bridgeport West Virginia yes mr.
Saunders I also want you you're very
easy to follow and you always vote with
the Democrat and actually you're a
socialist and this country isn't buying
socialism now I just watched says no on
CNN and he had two experts and were left
in the right and he put all these
questions to them it will not create
jobs it will not reduce the deficit and
I just don't I don't know how you can
sit there and say it's a bit it will and
what you're trying to do is cause class
warfare in this country and we don't
need it because we like to be rich we'd
like to get rich I'm not rich believe me
because I've got one child my husband
never made more than a thousand dollars
a month but yet i can put aside he just
retired two years ago and i can put
aside enough money to get an income from
thoughts with purchase and right now you
guys want to come along and take it away
from us i never took anything from the
government in welfare or anything I took
student once to put my child through
college and i'll be paying them for the
rest of their life as far as your little
program you have to put kids through
college i hope you get their end of it
first because we have people that have
gone through law school and medical
school on promise of giving their two
years at the other end to the needy and
they had programs on 60 minutes but they
never fulfill their end of the deal it's
a little
good convenient for their car I'm gonna
stop you there thanks for phoning in
congressman Sanders you know what makes
me a little bit sad is that the people
who owned the system and the people who
own the media have done an
extraordinarily good job I don't mind
when people who are wealthy who are
going to be asked to pay more in taxes
fight back all right that's
understandable but what is disturbing is
that a lot of working people have
swallowed that line themselves and what
they don't understand is that during the
1980s their taxes went up their ability
to send their kids to college went down
their housing bills went up their
insurance premiums went significantly
all of these problems accrued to them
and then the system has worked itself so
that you have working people defending
the interest of the very wealthy and I
think that's pretty sad but I would
disagree with that woman I think in fact
the reason the george bush was defeated
is that people finally finally after 12
years port on to what reaganomics was
about and it was a massive fraud what it
was was a shift of hundreds of billions
of dollars from poor and working people
to the very rich and finally people
caught on the woman says she doesn't
like class warfare nobody likes class
warfare nobody is advocating class
warfare but class warfare is exactly
what has been going on in this country
for the last dozen years when you have
children who are hungry at the same time
as the richest people in the country
enjoy a huge increase in their income
that is class warfare when you have
profitable corporations closing down in
america and moving to mexico and asia
where they gotta hire workers for fifty
cents an hour or a buck an hour and
throw people who have worked for that
company out on the streets after years
of service that is class warfare when
millions of people cannot afford to go
to a doctor or a hospital in this
country and we are the only nation in
the industrialized world not to have a
national health care system while other
people wealthy people can enjoy the best
quality health care in the entire world
that is class warfare so no one here is
advocating class warfare what we are
talking about is that class warfare
has gone on in this country for the last
dozen years and in fact in my view the
wrong side has been winning that war and
what we want to do now is to give a
little bit of help to working people
middle-income people hungry children
people who are sleeping out on the
street give them a fair shot in the
American dream it is not fair that the
wealthy guys I talked at Yale smoke at
Yale six months if I think the tuition
or the expenses yeah twenty-nine
thousand dollars a year how many
middle-income families working class
families can send their kid to school if
those type of course should every kid in
America have the opportunity to get a
college education yeah I think so but
you can need the government to play a
role to do that and one of the ways you
do that is you have to raise taxes and
if you raise taxes it should be upper
income people who pay the lion's share
not middle-income we're working people
congressman Santos will be with us a few
more minutes Sacramento your next thanks
for waiting oh hello Bernie Sanders
congressman uh I was wondering if you
were aware of the capital gains tax and
socialist Sweden you have any idea what
that is no no and sweetened is not 0
yeah zero in Finland to attack the
capital gain in Canada which has
socialized medicine do you have any idea
what that is none well if you buy a
house in Canada for 20,000 and you sell
it for two million the gain is not taxed
at all it is your now somehow these
socialist countries that everybody like
you wants this country to become when a
Japanese out I'm going to jump in just
from and I just one let our viewers know
that's Vice President Gore who was
leaving Capitol Hill he was meeting
earlier in the day throughout much of
the afternoon and early evening hours
working on the details of the House
Senate budget plan if you've just joined
us they did reach an agreement the
compromise announced about an hour and a
half or two hours ago by Speaker of the
House Tom Foley and Senator George
Mitchell the president will have more to
say tomorrow in the Roosevelt Room at
the White House when he will talking
further he will be talking further about
the plan he's also expected to address
the nation tomorrow evening and the vote
in a house in the Senate is expected to
come this thursday and friday will go
back to your call thanks for being
patient collar now the point is of Mr
Sanders is that some of these socialist
countries have figured out a way to keep
their
companies modern to pay for all these
wonderful programs that you want to
enact now you know a lot of people look
at this capital gains as well the
millionaires are going to be making a
going to be really raking in its not the
millionaire it's the fact that if you
want to have a modern society you got to
have a way of paying for it and the best
way is to do that is to allow companies
to modernize and you can't do that when
you know we tax our corporation so badly
you know i think i was in canada when i
explained to them that we tax dividends
forty percent off the top and then it's
a hundred percent to the taxpayer what
do you received we couldn't believe it
can I jump in and just make a quick
response the gentleman says that we tax
corporations so badly I'm sure that the
gentleman knows that the percentage of
revenue coming into the federal
government today from the corporate tax
is significantly less than it was 20 or
30 or 40 years ago and in fact during
those days this country led the world
was number one in terms of the standard
of living out people today we're in
number 12 place I don't know that there
is a correlation between the points that
you make it's time for one more call yep
Selanne mixing and go ahead please yes
this first time I call show i watch the
show Varrick and I like it thanks color
if you could turn the volume down on
your set that's how that's why we're
getting the echo will be able to hear
you a lot better okay but what I was
calling about to the representative
sannie staff I'd like to commend you
because you one of those that i watched
upon the yield and by watching the show
that are willing to stand up to Bob Dole
and rest of those peoples up there that
are wealthy that are taken away I'm a
Vietnam veteran come home I put three
kids through college I have a
ten-year-old that I'm working with and
it's hard for me to save money now to
try to you know put aside for his
education and I was explaining to him
that if we didn't help people like you
that will stand up and then a poor man
like me won't it make 25,000 miles a
year you know try to have a place for
him to get an education then we're gonna
be in bad shape somebody need to do
something I think President Clinton
Clinton is really trying at least he's
putting forth one package why some other
people said only tells not doing it
they hang come on hang up the phone and
listen to thanks for calling congressman
I think the gentleman is quite right and
I commend them there's so many people in
this country when making twenty thirty
thousand palsy who is struggling every
day here's a man making $25,000 e of
putting kids through college and I think
it is obligatory on the part of the
United States government to stand with
people like that with brave and
courageous people know the value of
education were fighting for their kids
lives and we must not turn our backs and
say that only the wealthy can afford to
go to college only the wealthy can
afford good quality healthy healthcare
only the wealthy can afford good housing
that's not what democracy is about now
one of the caller's pointed up early as
she thought that you know people were
becoming more and more conservative in
this country I don't think so i think
one of the things that makes me very sad
is that we have the lowest voter turnout
of any industrialized nation on earth in
the last election when people say oh the
turnout was really good forty five
percent of the people didn't vote in
this off presidential election that's
going to come up in a year and a half i
would guess forty forty five percent of
the american people gonna vote vast
majority of the people are not gonna
vote you know who doesn't vote poor
people don't vote working people don't
vote because they're so disgusted
they're so frustrated with a lack of
action on the part of government to
protect their interests and very often
they're giving Tweedledee Tweedledum
choice between Democrats and Republicans
alright so I think that if this country
is going to be saved if we're going to
turn it about if we can have decent jobs
for our kids if we're going to have a
national health care system if we're
going to put people to work cleaning up
the environment we're going to make sure
that everybody has a college education
who has the ability to get one we're
going to need to bring poor people and
working people into the political system
if you're in trouble now you can sit
back and let Bob Dole and the other
people make the decisions i would
suggest not to do that i would suggest
the working people and poor people get
involved start fighting for their rights
and the rights of their kids before I
let you go the House vote is on Thursday
how will it break down I suspect that
the Clinton woman by what margin it'll
be close congressman Sanders independent
from Vermont thanks for being with us
thank you we are going to continue
discussing the budget deal which was
announced earlier today coming up next
we'll be talking to congressman Phil
crane